vorrei chiudere gli occhi
ora occhi chiusi
un respiro
vorrei condurvi in un viaggio un viaggio
di nuove scoperte
immaginate di essere leggeri i vostri
piedi si staccano dal pavimento state
prendendo quota
ed ecco che iniziata a sorvolare una
terra bellissima meravigliosa ci sono
montagne innevate ci sono foreste
verdissime spiagge incontaminate
in che paese potremmo essere forse in
cina iniziamo a perdere quota ci
appoggiamo su questa terra e scopriamo
una terra pacifica dove non ci sono
dittatori dove tutti possono votare ed
esprimersi liberamente
allora forse siamo in india
no non può essere ci dicono che questa
sia la più grande potenza economica del
mondo
continuiamo a volare a volare a volare
ma è ovvio siamo in america
torniamo a perdere quota ci appoggiamo e
scopriamo tantissime nazioni ciascuna
con la propria cultura con le proprie
tradizioni e la propria lingua
allora dove potremmo essere
aprite gli occhi perché siete arrivati
questa terra meravigliosa e pacifica e
l'europa e grazie ad un'europa unita e
pacifica che oggigiorno
noi siamo più ricchi
siamo sicuramente in una posizione tale
da vivere più a lungo rispetto alle
generazioni che ci hanno preceduto
insomma l'europa e tutti noi di riflesso
non siamo mai stati meglio
eppure non sembriamo accorgercene
neppure quando vediamo persone disposte
ad andare in guerra più pur di
avvicinarsi a noi unirsi a noi neppure
quando vediamo persone disposte a
giocarsi la vita per raggiungere le
nostre coste
insomma stiamo diventando dei pessimisti
cronici quando si tratta di pensare al
nostro futuro insieme
alcuni paesi europei si accusano a
vicenda
altri vorrebbero addirittura andarsene
insomma è un po come se non ci fossero
più dei buoni motivi per stare insieme
per cortesia non fraintendetemi l'europa
è tutto tranne che perfetta
l'europa è così complessa che neppure
gli addetti ai lavori riescono a
districarne le fondamenta
fondamentalmente quando si parla di
europa siamo un po tutti euro analfabeti
non è colpa nostra
l'europa è avvolta da leggende da miti
che non ci permettono di capire come
funzioni che cosa faccia per tutti noi
vorrei sfatare questi miti smentire
queste leggende e lo farò uno ad uno per
distinguere ciò che è vero da ciò che è
falso e possibilmente per offrirvi un
altro sguardo su questa europa
economicamente debole poco democratica
tecnocratica
costosa è elitaria
l'europa emerge oggi come il nuovo
leviatano nell'immaginario collettivo
capro espiatorio di tutte le colpe dello
stato nazione
queste affermazioni
in realtà non superano la prova dei
fatti
si dice che l'europa non sia democratica
e in particolar modo che sia meno
democratica dei paesi che la compongono
a cominciare dall'italia in realtà studi
e le mie stesse ricerca dimostrano come
in realtà l'europa sia per lo meno
democratica come
i suoi singoli stati ed è addirittura
offra maggiori opportunità dei suoi
singoli stati per i cittadini di essere
parte del processo decisionale
chi decide in europa decidono i nostri
governi i rappresentanti dei nostri
governi insieme ai parlamentari che noi
stessi contribuiamo a leggere ogni
cinque anni
insomma chi decide a bruxelles non è
bruxelles sono i nostri rappresentanti
bruxelles non è un'entità terza si dice
che l'europa sia costosa che il suo
bilancio sia eccessivo rispetto ai
compiti che le sono affidati
ebbene se guardiamo al bilancio
dell'unione europea questo è pari all 1
per cento della ricchezza che produce
l'europa
sapete qual è il bilancio
della repubblica italiana
intorno al 50 per cento della sua
ricchezza
parliamo poi di impiegati il numero di
impiegati
delle istituzioni europee equivalente al
numero degli impiegati che lavorano nei
comuni della lombardia
63 mila impiegati con una differenza che
gli impiegati lombardi si occupano
fondamentalmente di poco più di un
milione di cittadini mentre quelli
europei si occupano di più di 500
milioni di cittadini
infine si dice dell'europa e questo il
mito più difficile da sfatare che sia
elitaria pochi eletti beneficerebbero di
questa bella europa
e qui ci terrei a dimostrarvi che non è
vero
tramite la mia storia
sono nato in italia
da una famiglia con poche inclinazioni
internazionali ma avuto la possibilità
grazie all'europa di studiare in
svizzera in belgio lavorare in
lussemburgo
oggi lavora in francia
vivo in spagna e proprio per dirvela
tutta mia moglie basca le mie figlie
sono un po confuse non parlano ancora
tanto bene ma fondamentalmente l'europa
ha dato una svolta alla mia vita così
come la data a milioni di cittadini
e forse anche ad alcuni di voi ed è per
questo che soffro soffro quando la vedo
maltrattata dai politici che le
addossano tutte le colpe e a volte si
appropriano dei suoi meriti ed è per
questo che soffro quando la vedo
falsificata dalla stampa ed è per questo
che soffro quando la vedo mal compresa
dai suoi cittadini inclusi i miei cari
miei amici la mia famiglia stessa
sapete quanti di noi cittadini europei
decidono di lasciare il loro paese per
stabilirsi in un altro paese europeo
ebbene siamo il 3 per cento
il 3 per cento
so esattamente cosa state pensando
ecco vedi siete i pochi eletti i
privilegiati
questo tuttavia non è corretto perché
noi il 3 per cento non siamo una casta
non siamo particolarmente ricchi non
siamo delle persone che vivono lontano
dalla vita realtà siamo parte di quella
realtà in realtà paghiamo le tasse
votiamo a volte a sinistra volte a
destra volte non votiamo esattamente
come tutti gli altri
fondamentalmente noi il 3 per cento
siamo la punta di un iceberg la parte
visibile dell'esperienza di vita europea
ma sapete quanti cittadini europei hanno
famiglia amici in un altro paese europeo
sapete quanti di loro
trascorrono del tempo in un altro paese
europeo almeno una volta all'anno ebbene
siamo il 50 per cento siamo dunque noi
che viviamo questa europa
siamo noi
che costruiamo un europa siamo noi e non
loro che stiamo creando uno spazio di
vita di vita nuovo e diverso forse è
anche il caso di incominciare a sentirci
orgogliosi
di questa europa
ad un certo momento nella vita tutti
studiamo cerchiamo un lavoro
cerchiamo un compagno una compagna un
marito compriamo casa
riuscite a pensare se anziché fare tutte
queste attività in un paese possiamo
farlo in 28 e allo stesso tempo
questa è l'essenza dell'europa la
possibilità di realizzarsi in uno spazio
geografico e mentale più ampio rispetto
a quello in cui siamo nati
questa è l'europa
l'europa e adesso ed è nostra
l'europa non è sempre stata un
catalizzatore di opportunità di certo
non è stata per i nostri antenati per i
nostri bisnonni e nonni per cui l'europa
è stata una barriera
non un'opportunità
mio nonno
alla mia età viveva in libia
vi è rimasto quasi vent'anni a
combattere contro gli inglesi quando è
rientrato si è trovato di fronte
all'occupazione tedesca prima di
incontrare mia nonna
oggi i miei migliori amici sono i
discendenti
dei nemici di mio nonno ed è miei figli
giocano con i loro figli
tutto questo è avvenuto in meno di tre
generazioni
eppure continuiamo a non vedere l'europa
in questi termini
l'europa e non vedere l'europa oggi
significa perdere delle opportunità non
soltanto per noi ma anche per i nostri
figli ei figli dei nostri figli
insomma fatemelo dire
è un po come vincere lotto e non
riscuotere il montepremi attenzione di
nuovo non vi sto dicendo di innamorarvi
dell'europa ma già che ci siete magari
godete di questa europa approfittate di
questa europa
nel momento in cui non siamo mai stati
così pacificamente interconnessi a
livello globale ci ostiniamo a guardare
il mondo dal nostro orticello
siamo ancorati allo stato nazione che si
tratti dell'educazione che si tratti del
mondo del lavoro della stampa della
politica
siamo comunque sempre in una posizione
che nazionale
sapete che a forza di fare così ci
concentriamo sugli alberi e perdiamo di
vista la foresta e soltanto se saremo in
grado di ribaltare questa prospettiva
ribaltare questa prospettiva che potremo
iniziare a vedere l'europa come
un'opportunità
divisi abbiamo massacrato l'europa
insieme l'abbiamo ricostruita
ora è il momento di viverla
abbiamo il dovere morale noi abitanti
della civiltà più evoluta al mondo di
capire e trasmettere questo messaggio e
possibilmente di pensare quotidianamente
al senso del nostro vivere insieme per
fare ciò dobbiamo essere in grado di
scardinare la mentalità dominante quella
imposta ci dai politici dalla stampa dai
poteri forti
perché in realtà non è soltanto l'europa
che ci è stata nascosta c'è di più
è la nostra capacità di essere artefici
delle nostre esistenze
insieme abbiamo intrapreso un viaggio un
viaggio alla scoperta dell'europa e lo
abbiamo fatto con gli occhi chiusi
ora è tempo più che mai di aprire i
nostri occhi grazie